well folks the Stewie 2K Saga has
finally turned a new page after over
half a year of dismal results and
uncertainty Stewie announced that he
would be stepping away from competitive
play to focus on content creation for EG
playing both CS go and valorent let's
unpack what we know and see if we can't
read into the future
[Music]
now before we get into the video I
wanted to let you all know that we'll be
co-streaming Evo this year on our twitch
channel from August 5th to the 7th if
you like fighting games or just want to
stop by and hang out we'd love for you
guys to be there it's going to be a lot
of fun so as you guys might already know
Stewie 2K left Team Liquid back in
January to play for Evil Geniuses along
with the rest of the roster Na and CS
fans alike we're all excited to see what
they could pull off unfortunately things
did not pan out that way players all
around this a site a little jump towards
ticket that's a great invitation but a
deadly invitation from dumow
down goes EG forward moves godsend that
was uh that was a little bit hard to
watch you know you try to find several
Linings I'm sure the desk is going to
have a lot more to say but they were
just very few redeeming qualities about
that match from EG they failed to make
it to Antwerp Dallas and really any
important event it was a massive blow
for an orc trying to revitalize itself
in Stewie well he was almost always the
center of attention for every hiccup if
this EG roster was an experiment it was
definitely a failed one every solution
they threw at it was a Band-Aid on a
bullet wound culminating them turning
into a rotating 15-man roster instead of
taking a step back and sort of
recalibrating
EG doubled down
in fact they tripled down to the shock
of pretty much the entire Esports World
EG announced that they'd signed both
party astronauts and Carpe diems so as
to forge and field a staggering
15-person CS go roster since then things
have been up in the air and Stewie
hadn't really played with the team
properly since the end of April as a
result everyone's been patiently waiting
for an update and we finally got it and
it definitely surprised a few people via
Twitter EG and Stu both announced that
he'd be stepping away from competitive
CS go to do content creation for the orc
focusing on both CS go and valorent now
if you've been tuning into his streams
that's not that big of a surprise since
he's been juggling both games for quite
some time now and when I say juggling I
mean recently he's been absolutely
ripping ballerant
I also say it's not surprising because
people have long speculated that Stewie
would eventually make the switch to
valorent I just think most people didn't
expect him to make a hard switch
straight to content creation but it's
important to note that at the end of his
tweet Stu does say that his future is
not set in stone so it is possible that
we'll one day see him return to Pro play
in really either game and yes this means
we now live in a universe where there is
a tiny chance of seeing Stewie vs shroud
in valorant what a timeline that would
be that being said sticking to content
creation might be the move we've already
seen the likes of tarek someone with the
exact same pedigree as him explode in
popularity over the last year or so
Stewie already has a pretty big
personality and a solid following so if
he's able to develop himself as a
streamer it can be pretty lucrative
watch parties collaborations you name it
it's all on the table for him and so far
his numbers have been great the question
is does Stewie still have that
competitive itch my guess is that he
does but he made it very clear that he's
taking his brand seriously and that he's
not trying to rush into anything just
yet I'm not in a rush to play Valerie
professional I'm not closing the door on
any like Pro offers I'm open to it
um I think right now
I'm just gonna try to observe a little
bit in valorent I'm gonna try to watch
some games yeah just kind of feel it out
like fill out the protein but with all
the attention that shrouds return
brought I'm sure there's no shortage of
teams interested in doing the same thing
with Stewie for now it's all just
speculation and I'm sure if something
were to happen it wouldn't be too soon
although Stewie has made his Pie in the
Sky dream known to the public what's my
dream team in Val
if one day me and Tara team up again I'm
telling you right now everybody in Valor
y'all better watch out in my opinion
this was the best possible moves do we
could have made he clearly loves to play
Valerian and stream and at least for him
the EG nightmare is finally over
um I think like what I'm curious to see
is like I always found Stewie a little
bit like
not low energy but like he really needed
to be in the competitive environment to
like really bring out his energy so I'm
curious like how long it's going to take
him to be able to like translate that to
content creation because for like
someone like Tarik it was like almost
instantly he was able to just be like
super fiery and Stewie is super fiery
but like we've only seen that in in Pro
play and if you've ever seen his streams
before it's like he he definitely tries
but it's more like it's not as like
natural as it is when he's like on stage
so curious to see that happen